so machen wir ein bisschen bildungs
unterricht liebe zuschauer in
1974 also vor gut 50 jahren wurde das
wahlalter von 21 auf 18 heruntergesetzt
ziel war es mehr menschen für politik zu
begeistern
die ampel koalition will es auf 16
jahren heruntersetzen so steht es im
koalitionsvertrag ganz genau aber jetzt
liebe zuschauer der absolute gaga
vorschlag wahlrecht für kita kinder also
quasi babys an die urne die jüngste
abgeordnete der grünen die gerade einmal
24 jährige volksvertreterin emilia
fester die hat jetzt gefordert wahlrecht
ab zwei jahren das ist ihr wunsch wie
sie im gespräch mit dem fast 80 jährigen
wolfgang schäuble sagte schäuble ist der
alterspräsident im bundestag also
sozusagen das genaue gegenteil von
fester ja und darüber wollen wir jetzt
sprechen mit bild politik chef jan
schäfer schön dass du da bist hallo jan
walle montag wasser ist so persönlich
von dem vorschlag wahlrecht ab zwei
jahren wer hat das schon ganz gut
intoniert dem kann ich mich nur
anschließen dieser vorschlag ist
natürlich für die tonne um es einmal so
deutlich zu sagen
emilia fester ist bekannt dafür dass sie
den bundestag und alles was da passiert
er auf spielerische art und weise
eigentlich betrachtet und das auch in
die öffentlichkeit trägt da kann man
immer darüber streiten man kann auch
darüber streiten über die frage müssen
kinder stärker gehör im bundestag finden
und bei entscheidungen aber jetzt zu
sagen auch ein zweijähriger oder eine
zweijährige dürfte wählen das ist
natürlich völlig absurd wir wissen da
wählt nicht das kind selbst oder das
baby selbst sondern da würden die eltern
am ende wählen und ja da ist die große
frage bekommen die ein zusätzlicher
stimmrecht dann oder eben nicht aber ist
klar wie das ganze ausgehen würde aber
ist es von ihr wirklich ernst gemeint
oder doch eher ein gaga vorschlag um
mehr gehört zu bekommen also sie ist ja
auch bekannt dafür dass das gesagt was
hat sie bisher sonst noch für aktionen
gebracht bislang um einmal bei den
vorschlag zu bleiben vielleicht das ist
etwas was sie ja schon des öfteren
eigentlich postuliert hat immer wieder
gesagt dass das wahlalter zu hoch ist
und weiter abgesenkt werden sollen sie
ist damit nicht alleine wir haben
gestern gesprochen mit der
bildungspolitischen sprecherin der fdp
ria schröder und die sieht das ähnlich
die sagt auch das wahlalter sollte
deutlich abgesenkt werden sagt sogar
sollte eigentlich gar keinen wahlalter
mehr geben wer lust hat und da sagt sie
hier bei uns beide wer lust hat der soll
einfach auswählen können also wir sehen
da gibt es unter den jüngeren
abgeordneten bundestag durchaus viel
sympathie für so einen vorstoß das heißt
also wenn ich mir mehr kinder ich habe
desto mehr ihr habt bestimmt nicht habe
ich eigentlich dann auch also weil ja
immer auch schon angesprochen hast dann
wählen natürlich auch eltern für ihre
kinder genau es gibt unter ökonomen eine
ernst zu nehmende debatte immer mal
wieder genau über diese frage ist es
eigentlich in ordnung dass jeder nur
eine stimme hat oder ist es nicht auch
in ordnung dass familien mütter und
väter beispielsweise auch die chance
bekommen im sinne ihrer kinder politik
mit zu beeinflussenden manchmal haben
natürlich kinder und auch eltern andere
interessen beispielsweise als jemand der
schon im ruhestand ist diese debatte
wird immer wieder hitzig geführt aber da
geht es dann eher um ein elternwahlrecht
hier für kinder hier ist etwas völlig
anderes was im jahr fester und auch hier
schröder vorschlagen hier geht es
wirklich darum dass ich über spitze
jetzt babys an die wahlurne sollen und
das ist natürlich absurd dass uns dann
nochmal auf die personalie emilia
fenster schauen sie hat er schon während
der korona pandemie damit polarisiert
das sie gesagt hat sie küsst weniger
menschen um sich so zu schützen ja immer
ja fest da ist in diesem bundestag
eingezogen man hat den eindruck manchmal
nutzt sie das einfach als ganz ganz
große show bühne und zwar um sich in
pose zu setzen und nicht um ernsthafte
politik zu betreiben sie macht das immer
wieder in der tat tritt bei tik tok auch
auf mit dem ein oder anderen für mich
jetzt gewöhnungsbedürftigen video ich
bin nicht sicher ob das ankommt jeder
soll politik machen auf seine art und
weise aber was wir hier sehen ist doch
eine starke infantilisierung von politik
also eine verächtlichmachung und einem
ins lächerliche ziehen und das muss man
sagen das ist am ende dann wenn man
schaut auch was sie mir ja fester bisher
bewegt hat dann doch maßlos übertrieben
emilia fester ist junge bundestag ist
die jüngste abgeordnete hat sicherlich
auch das recht zu polarisieren ohne
frage aber am ende ist das ganze ja
keine schauspieler wurde der bundestag
soll hier werden ernsthafte gesetze
gemacht hier geht es um gesetze für die
wichtigste und größte volkswirtschaft
europas
für eine führungsmacht und der klamauk
der hier zum teil stattfindet den finde
ich ehrlich gesagt unerträglich werden
einiges von ihm hören von dir auch
besten dankt herrn schäfer ja